hot breath like i would say that even
the comedian the one i started off with
this guy has
a 12 tonight shows bro with jay leno
but he doesn't work social media
he doesn't know how to use the instagram
he doesn't know how to use none of that
but if that guy would have been the
first to do it you know what i mean
yeah he's gonna tweet with dan cook you
gotta know the latest
like if you wanna learn what's new just
listen to howard stern
i mean you don't do howard stern or any
like any podcast
that's relevant like joe rogan or mark
marin you can you're gonna know about
the latest gadgets
what to get learn from other
learn from successful comments like
kevin hart like what does he do every
day
he gets up every morning he gets on a
treadmill he works out weights
he does five hours of interviews and
there's a lot of comics who can't do
interviews
like they go to radio and they let the
they let the radio guys do all the
talking
and they leave the radio station without
mentioning their show
without mentioning word of advice for
any comedian if the community if the
first of all when you get to the radar
station they don't know who you are
okay they have a list oh you're a
comedian and you've been on this they're
reading off your
wikipedia or your resume as you get
there mm-hmm
this is what you do we have a little
[Applause]
that's right felipe sparks is here and
i'm going with the punchline this week
you say your name and you say we're
going to be at
if you don't like where the conversation
is going just every time they go to you
felipe esparza at the punch line i
learned that from margaret's show
nice i was doing an interview with
gabriel galescia to promote his show at
the punch line
and margaret show fox talks it comes in
how you guys doing margaret show i'm
gonna be at the wilbur theater
i'm gonna be the warfield theater eight
o'clock two shows
how you been margaret show i've been
great i'm gonna be at the
wilford theater eight o'clock august
show eight o'clock
and she didn't say [__] just put that
but uh but her um interview
i've seen these two comedians do man cow
and man call probably insult to the
community like you wearing makeup
and then you just stood quiet like ah no
no interview is going to go your way you
got to make it your way
it goes back to you're saying one of the
best ways to make it is to have a big
personality yeah
be outgoing you can't be lame man yeah
or if you don't know how to interview go
check out go go to app and go how do i
could i interview better make good
answers like they tell you
what do you like about school lunch
don't ever answer a question like that
what you answer the question like this
so the listener can know what question
you're answering
what i like about lunch first of all is
lunch
i like burritos i hate studying in line
you know i hate when i lose my
my meal ticket details bro
details i hate when
you ask a person a question and go yeah
[__] that dude i want to punch him in a
[__] base dude
if i don't get a long answer from you
you better get the [__] at the podcast
yeah i hate when i gotta do all the
talking because people are lame
they're [__] shy i hate it bro
i hate when they have a i gotta do a
podcast from our publicist and
we have a young person who doesn't know
how to do interviews so
you have a new album come out yeah
okay you fat ass
where is it coming out at
[Laughter]
and another thing also if you're going
to be a guest on a podcast
as soon as you get off the podcast go
tell people you're on that podcast
if you're begging to be on a podcast one
thing i hate the most is you beg to be
on my podcast
and then when i post that you're going
to be on my podcast with a photo
and you don't retweet it like i did a
podcast with this guy right here
and i kept going after that comment bro
where are you gonna put the [__]
podcast up
and he never even put in his [__]
page what ron philippe esparza you're
nobody
i know who you are that's why you're
here yeah i'm no one
i kept asking them where are you gonna
put the podcast up what are you gonna
bro i took time to do your podcast
you never put it up i want to kill him
bro
i wasted my time on your lame podcast he
didn't put it up
[__] that [__] bro well we're
putting this one willie barcelo
kicked his ass i was happy a word
[Laughter]
but the guy i started off with he's
crazy now bro
now he's crazy bro i assumed he was back
then he found out that that comedian was
doing his joke
and he was on his way to vegas from
corpus he made a u-turn
and went to el paso and went to a
restaurant and tried to kick his ass
jeez that's what you get bro for not
posting that podcast
i don't understand how you can have a
podcast and not post it on your page and
put your lane comedy there
i don't know this one's going up though
i promise i don't want to get killed
you